we think on a frequency and the
frequency we think undec Tate's the
results we get wanna be happy
build a life not just the business hey
it's Evan Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you to you
have Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn how you can start
thinking on a higher frequency also if
you want to have more motivation and
confidence check out my 254 series
they're free the link to join on the
description below what we've kind of
understand is we're treating our life
for our goals literally trading our life
I was reminded this morning of a
question I'm often asked how do you
eliminate fear from your life all things
are possible if you believe okay let's
kick it off with the most important rule
make a decision on a time to you about
forming a habit that literally change
your world I formed this habit a long
time ago and I'm going to tell you my
world changed like night day work for me
it'll work for you
decision is something most people never
really learn and for good reason stay
with me because I'm going to show you
something here that you possibly have
never looked at before this book changed
everything for me in this book it's
Napoleon Hills Think and Grow Rich
there's 15 chapters there's one chapter
the entire chapter is dedicated to
decision now you may say well I make
decisions do you really you may make
little ones but to make the real
important ones do you go after what you
want in life
do you get everything you want in life
see the truth is only about 3% of the
people are really living the way they
want to live driving the car they want
to drive taking the trips they want to
take living in the houses they want to
live in most people do not and they'll
tell you why they can't and they'll give
you a string of reasons a mile long all
seem very practical very reasonable
and the leader of them all is they can't
afford it well the truth is we live in
the richest country in the history of
the world money is the easiest thing in
the world turn once you learn how well
if you turn making a decision into a
habit you're gonna learn how to do a
whole lot of things you may think you
can't do see what we're doing is we're
exploring a site of our personality that
we really don't understand we're dealing
with the site of our personality that
most people do not understand what you
see here is not me this is my body
you never hear anyone say am hand you
see we've got to take a look at the
non-physical side of ourselves Lincoln
President Lincoln put that very well he
said to believe in the things you can
see and touch is no belief at all but to
believe in the unseen is a triumph and a
blessing well let's look at this making
a decision we're going into the unseen
part of ourselves using faculties most
people don't even know they've got you
see Einstein said the intuitive mind is
a sacred gift well he said the rational
mind is a faithful servant he said we
have created a society that honors the
servant has forgotten the gift what is a
servant well there it is there
it's our century factors we can see hear
smell taste touch what are they for
there to help us correspond and
communicate with our outside world but
you know that the physical world is
nothing but the manifestation of the
non-physical world that's right here
we've got something that's nothing short
of a miracle
when we look at it properly this is a
little cell phone it has more power than
the computer head that took the first
rocket to the moon think of that and I'm
carrying it around in my pocket I can
touch a button and bang like that send a
picture to you and you'll get it
simultaneous with me sending it how does
all that happen well it happens because
we're dealing with the non sight
non-physical side of ourselves we're
dealing with just pure power how do we
get at that well we've been gifted we've
been gifted with something no other form
of
life has we have these higher faculties
you've got perception memory imagination
will reason intuition I want you to
shift your perception for a moment of
yourself
you know our good friend the late Wayne
Dyer he put it very well he said when
you change the way you look at something
what you look out will change change
your perception you know the reason most
people don't make decisions because they
can't see how they're going to get there
so what do they do they keep doing
things that they can see how they're
going to get there and that's why their
life never really changes stick with me
here for a moment think of you you are a
mass of energy and you function on
frequencies that's what you are take a
look at yourself
here's a shot taken by Kirlian
photography
Semyon Kirlian was a Russian who
perfected a form of photography way back
in the early 30s
that'll photograph mass where you can
photographed the energy leaving the body
there's a glow of energy around you this
physical thing we live in is a massive
energy well we're going to be talking
about the non-physical side you see a
frequency is a level of vibration
general vibration is a natural law of
the universe everything vibrates nothing
rests we live in an ocean of motion now
there's an infinite number of
frequencies
now get this let all these lines
represent levels of vibration okay
levels of vibration as we said are
referred to as frequencies you and I
think on frequencies the highest
function we're capable of now here's
where you really want to pay attention
this if you get this if I communicate
this effectively your life can change
because it sure changed mine we think on
a frequency and the frequency we think
on dictates the results we get so we're
sitting here and they say these are me
results but this is where I really want
to go and we point to a star somebody
said what do you really want I really
want to be wealthy do you know that most
people never live the way they really
want to live they don't they never do in
the amount of money they can they don't
live in the house they really want
they don't take their vacations they
really want to take why because they
don't know how you see when they set
those targets they look off into a space
and they see nothing
now look here for a moment these lines
represent levels of frequency or you
could say levels of awareness but when
we set the target way up there it's all
gone we don't know how to get there
think of that think of what Steve Jobs
says you cannot connect the dots looking
forward you can only connect them
looking backwards so you have to trust
that the dots are going to connect as
you go ahead now that's pretty big if
you're gonna look at the unseen you have
to use the higher faculties
that's what Einstein talked about the
sacred gift we can use faculties to look
into the future we can go into the
future with our imagination and see
ourself where we want to be your from
now and then bring that into the present
and begin acting like the person we want
to become when you make the decision
everything starts to change look at this
for a moment you're thinking down here
on this frequency and that's what's
giving you the results you're getting if
you want to go where you say do you want
to go you've got to get on that
frequency you see the truth is you're
not thinking about getting there you're
letting the present results repeat and
that's the star you're shooting at
you're going to get the same results
over and over and over again as long as
you said keep your thinking there you
got to get your thinking up on this
higher frequency because when you get on
that frequency the thoughts and things
that are gonna come into your mind will
take you there how do you think we got
to the moon Kennedy didn't know how to
get to the moon when he asked dr.
Wernher von Braun who's considered this
father of the space program what will it
take for us to build a rocket carry a
man to the moon he and bring him back
safely to earth he said the will to do
it
the will is one of the higher faculties
that's what Einstein was talking about
will gives you the ability to focus on
one thing to the exclusion of everything
else when you focus on that one thing
you're on that higher frequency how do
you do that well first you got to make a
decision to go there you see your mind
and thoughts must be focused on the same
frequency as your goal how do we do that
we make a committed decision that's
where I'm going and when you make the
committed decision that's irrevocable
you cannot go back you shut the past off
you begin thinking on this higher
frequency and you think an act like the
person you want to become
does it sound preposterous that's what
the Wright brothers did and they
introduced us to New Kingdom now I have
a special bonus clip from Mel Robbins on
how to make energizing decisions that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching a
video to taking action here we go
question number one what's the decision
that you need to make number two who are
three people who energize you and number
three how will you stay committed to the
decision that you make and if you made
it this far in the video I want to
celebrate you give me a hashtag believe
down the comments any decision can be
divided into what do I need to do versus
how and when do I need to do it for the
what that is intuition and by intuition
I use the word energy and the way to
answer any question for yourself
personally that you don't immediately
know the answer to is to ask this
question does it energize and expand my
life or does it shrink it if it
energizes and expands your life the
answer is hell yes you should absolutely
do it that is what you should do if the
decision shrinks you or it deflates you
then the answer's hell no you should not
do it this is an incredible tool to use
in deal-making by the way because you
know I'm in the middle of negotiating a
massive media deal at the moment and
it's something I've always wanted to do
and when you're negotiating for
something you really want whether it's
somebody that you're dating or you know
it's a salary or whatever it in my case
it's a massive media deal you can get
really ego driven right right you can
start to get very attached to the deal
or to the person yes or whatever but you
have to stop and ask yourself is this
deal or this person actually expanding
and energizing me are or are there
aspects of it that deplete and shrink me
and if there's any aspect of it that
depletes and shrinks you either have to
change that aspect of the deal or the
relationship structure where you have to
say no period right if you decide that
yet it energizes me and I really want to
do it then that's what you want next
you've got to think about the outcome
which is how and when you make it happen
if you want to know the easiest way to
become a millionaire check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there
time is your greatest friend here and if
you get in the game you're gonna win and
you need to get the game now not wait to
your business to success you have to own
assets